il mio nome
è
[Musica]
[Applauso]
a
bella tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
modo io sono pari j
oggi stavo nuovamente su saggio
simonetto il ragazzo ha detto che era
finito perché effettivamente sergio
stimato l'abbiamo finito soltanto che
uscito un dlc che mi avete consigliati
in 450mila persone in una settimana
intera che praticamente consiste nell
usare una cassetta qui a destra questa
qui se ne scappano mi ricordo come si
usano i comandi perché il povero dottore
non può neanche andare in vacanza che lo
stressano con questi nuovi dl 7 va bene
non è anche centrato il vano per la
cassetta ma entriamo l'hotel
ok è qualcosa molto alla james bond
vabbè dove cazzo siamo nello studio
bones ok sta roba
beh ragazzi il prestigioso talento di
dottor fa vj richiesto nuovamente per i
pazienti del mondo e andiamo
direttamente su team fortress perché
siamo ragazzi [ __ ] i guanti oggi
mi sento un ribella allora facciamo così
come cos'è cos'è questo non è una sala
operatore cos'è sta perché c'erano già
insanguinata non ho fatto nulla
beh ragazzi questa volta mi sa che forse
ciò sono un tentativo quindi mi sa che
sei spacciato amico mia me ne servono
almeno 3 ma va bene scherza scalzava
tranquillo perché accoglie nick emea non
puoi farlo faccio io allora perfetto ci
siamo bene allora ragazzi dobbiamo e
dobbiamo fare che cos'è questo perché
c'è una bomba no oddio bicolore che ho
avuto l'alto bene bene non è caduta la
bomba dal tavolo quindi siamo stati
benissimo
amico mio che cosa hai fatto per finire
qui dentro non capiva presenti già che
ci siamo facciamo c'è una bevuta da
amici e meglio dell'anestesia amico mio
tutto ciò ok erano ragazzini ti lascio
la bottiglia lì se vuoi dov'è il mio
martello dove cazzo e hutch lanciò la
mazza da baseball in compenso vabbè
proviamo con questa vediamo di riuscire
a operare come si deve con gli attrezzi
giusti professionali mazza da baseball e
ci siamo allora vien hamas perché la
madonna santissima perché c'ha i quali
moni biol amico mio quanto cazzo fumi e
vabbè senti fa così mangia mangiati
tutto è l'ormai anche se frigo qui non
so come mai
vabbè togli il braccio che devo prendere
la nutella togliti dai cazzo o che ci si
sa mai dove la nutella de falco zen
perché ci sono due cuori intrecciati
cos'è sta roba
ragazzi ma chi è che tiene due cuori in
frigorifero a seguito dell seguite lo
mangi poi a colazione se fai il bravo
paziente voglio capire perché ci sono
due cuori che cazzo mi devo fare io
cos'è cos'è sta roba
marcorè di un mammut ci si starà mai
dentro sto cuore maledetto stronzo
cosa vuoi che faccia i miei 55 anni di
carriera la medico non ho mai visto i
polmoni viola ma l'edizione usa una
sigaretta elettronica fa qualcosa ma non
puoi
va bene allora i ragazzi siamo sono già
arrivato al quale direi di riuscire se
riesco a prendere a tagliarlo come si
deve ma dato che non ho
non ho di bisturi direi di utilizzare
degli attrezzi che il servono per
tagliare quegli attrezzi molto
professionali quali una matita anche un
cacciavite in certi casi può essere
utile devo riuscire a tagliarli con
qualcosa ragazzi ci abbiamo degli
attrezzi che sono utilizzati nelle
migliori ospedali del mondo e nei
migliori saliti chirurgia del pianeta
terra che sono un cacciavite e una
matita è con questi riuscire a tagliare
il cuore se ci sono riuscito
ciao ragazzi mag amiche ma chi è che
conoscete mai che riesce a tagliare un
cuore con un cacciavite che ho sembra
una carota
vabbè grazie a questo qua in cacciavite
molto speciale perché una volta che ci
taglia il cuore devi sapere che la
paziente che questo è un cacciavite
multiuso se tu apri la bocca adesso
controlliamo le carie
perché questo è un cacciavite che sa io
sono anche un dentista sono tutto vedi
di aprire la spalanca la bocca faia
brava allora un paio di cari al in fondo
ma non importa lava tdp denti e fai il
bravo bambino
allora ragazzi dobbiamo dobbiamo
riuscire a togliere il cuore è lì
perfetto la devo riuscire a togliere che
sparava che non ho ben capito che cos'è
tali firme sotto specie di ectoplasma
cos'è è un ectoplasma ma penso che a
perfetto che cos'è sta roba che razza di
alieno è quello dacci un segno alla
ragazze ti fai una buona cosa mangiate
lo magari ti serve per la pulizia dei
denti
va bene allora ghazi quale l'abbiamo
tolto serve quello nuovo che non ho
capito bene è stata l'aspettate facciamo
facete melo togliere e mettiamolo qui
già che ci siamo quindi così almeno ci
siano cazzo
cos'è è partita in orbita la vaschetta
la prendo al volo
cazzo è andato troppo avanti va beh non
importa brutto stronzo non è visto
niente tu verona bravo d'armi che poi
tra l'altro oddio cos'è
apri la bocca stronzo apri la bocca
while cos'è e questo un trattamento sexy
che si fa i pazienti una cosa molto
erotica perfetto da ragazzi io direi che
possiamo mettere il cuore
qual è il cuore nuovo di preciso direi
questo perché l'altro è troppo grosso
che non c entra manco in un cavallo allo
ragazzi no fermo che sta morendo
pacchetti veloce no è durato troppo è
andato troppo sotto cazzo devi uscire 6
che faccia ce la faccio dai raga abbiamo
perso il cuore cosa ok dai proviamoci
non so se funzionava bene col cuore del
mammut mai così cazzo che costo cuore
vivi 300 anni
fammi sentire che ci sei bustocca
insistito mesnile va bene ragazzi è come
primo tentativo ho fatto cagare
ma ci riproviamo allora micróbio vediamo
di chiarirci subito allora ti sto
aprendo il coraggio con una bomba
atomica e non è una cosa normale solo
dottor pa vj fa queste cose
professionali quindi nessun altro
dottore al mondo adesso appare quindi
collabora con me e vivi stavolta
maledizione cazzo sto morendo
no all'orto o bisogno ragazzi ho bisogno
di qualcosa per farlo vivere accusiamo
il vad carbonica
beh visti
ma perché è il modica da quando il vodka
fa male
ragazzi siamo lì ma voglio vedere se
riesco a tagliare sta roba in qualche
modo allora spettatore come ho fatto
prima non ne ho idea non ci riuscirò mai
più
se riesco a ritagliarmi non ci credo non
ci credo preso un attrezzo a casa ce la
sto facendo
allora è il cuore ce l'abbiamo e non so
tirarlo fuori se si guarda stronzo stato
attirato fuori un'altra volta
allora ragazzi dobbiamo riuscire a
metterlo dentro l'altro cuore però dove
trovarlo e lì dentro una volta ci dovrei
essere in dovrebbe essere quello piccolo
il cuore giusto perché con le norme ed
esageratamente grossa no no no no no
calmi ragazzi calmi che mi stava
partendo in orbita al cuore rega sono
riuscito a trovare lynnfield a cuore
cioè non so se pazzo
allora è fermi fermi un attimo devo
riuscire a fermi è la cosa
incasinatissima ragazzi è una cosa
impossibile ma ci si può proprio dire
che siamo ragazzi mi sposo quale non so
che fare un mio dio non c'è più niente
giù sono quello enorme ma non serve e
babe la ringrazio amico mi è stato un
piacere alla prossima
[Musica]
james madison
l'america è una cosa assurda non ci sono
riuscito perché è impossibile
è l'operazione più difficile finora
assurda quindi io la concludo qui perché
non ce la faccio più tocca il city come
stai
va bene allora ragazzi basta no
migliora la cosa impossibile anche se vi
dove piaciuto lasciate un commento mi
piace anche alla pagina di facebook e
come non i video trovate nella
descrizione se non siete riusciti
iscrivetevi e ci vediamo nel prossimo
video bella ragazzi
[Musica]